do any of you remember phantom ward well
way back in the day phantom Ward or
James Varga was a relatively popular
csgo streamer allegedly he ran an
illegal skin gambling website that he'd
rigged and he got banned for that and
then he sued twitch now that's all
pretty standard knowledge it's happened
in the past but what's new here is that
last week the judge ruled that vargas
contract which was unconscionable and
that he's entitled to sue for a lot more
than anyone thought
all right let's back this up a little
bit Bentham Ward was banned from twitch
way back in 2016 during a sleep that
targeted streamers who were involved in
the csgo skin gambling saying if you
don't member that whole thing then
basically what happened was there were a
lot of websites around shady websites
that let you gamble on match results or
a random casino games like roulette sore
coin flips using csgo skins as your
gambling chips this kind of became a
huge problem because csgo like a lot of
video games has a large audience of
people who are maybe too young to
legally gamble in a lot of states or
countries now eventually made a ruling
that any sites using their API for
third-party gambling websites we're
breaking these team Terms of Service
which meant that they could be banned in
twitches Terms of Service it says that
if you're breaking or violating the
terms of service of any game or service
you're using on twitch you yourself can
be banned from twitch for that and
really all of this makes sense
twitch like csgo like again a lot of
video games has a pretty large audience
of young people who are not allowed to
legally gamble and it's kind of
dangerous to let them do something that
even though it doesn't visually resemble
gambling because you're using csgo skins
it's still gambling because those things
have monetary value alright now let's
get back to phantom art according to
report from way back in 2016 by e sports
journalist Richard Lewis phantom board
allegedly ran one of these shady
gambling sites the site was called csgo
shuffle and allegedly phantom Ward Riggs
the results of that site in his videos
and twitch streams for advertising
purposes in those videos and streams he
also allegedly didn't disclose that he
was involved with the site alright so
this actually happened a lot back in the
day when all these gambling sites were
all over the place the idea was that you
make a video you'd say that you won some
thousands of dollars in skins by only
betting a hundred or ten or you won
10,000 and only bet 5,000 right
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
people would then use your skin gambling
site because they saw somebody winning
there's a pretty classic casino trick
right you put the people who are winning
out front so that people want to come in
and they'll win - in theory the issue is
that if you owned the casino and you're
rigging your own result you're breaking
a whole lot of laws doing all this and
well it's disingenuous at the very least
so obviously this all sounds pretty bad
and of course because he was breaking
these steam terms of service he was
breaking the twitch Terms of Service and
twitch summarily banned him and that's
the end of the story right wrong about a
year later Vario made a YouTube video in
which he cleared the air and explained
what was going on between him and twitch
unfortunately he deleted the YouTube
video so all we have left is a polygon
report about what he said according to
the report he said in that video that he
wasn't being sued he was just laying low
for a bet then he allegedly read a
statement from a lawyer which goes
something like this as many of you are
already aware there is an ongoing
dispute between myself and twitch TV as
a result I am not currently providing
content through twitch.tv but I cannot
and will not comment on the substance of
this dispute I assure you that I'm
considering all my legal options and I'm
looking forward to asserting my rights
to the fullest extent of the law and
then in 2018 almost two years after
being banned from twitch Fanta board
actually sued them and his legal case
sounds kind of reasonable to me
according to phantom Ward P signed a
contract with twitch in 2015 as part of
his twitch partner agreement and every
major streamer signs one of these he
says that in that contract there was a
clause that which had written in that
said if they ever banned him for any
reason or broke the partnership
agreement is more accurate they needed
to give him a written explanation of why
they did so now phantom Ward says that
never happened he never got his written
explanation but I want to take a sec
to really talk about that this dude had
a contract with twitch that basically
said that they needed to give him a
doctor's note if they wanted to skip
school now I'm not a lawyer but this
sounds ridiculous and kind of
unenforceable
it seems super easy to just forget to
write a note when you have to ban
someone's ass anyway fandom Ward says he
never got the note which means that
twitch broke their own contract with him
and he's entitled to damages so here's
where the news comes in on September
27th judge Curtis Karnow of the
California Superior Court ruled that a
specific clause in phantom Wars
contracts with twitch was unconcious the
cause a $50,000 cap on how much he was
entitled to sue twitch because probably
none of us are lawyers here
unconscionable in legal terms means that
a cause and a contract is far too
one-sided it favors one party far more
than it favors the other which is not
really cool in contract law and again I
want to reiterate here the contract
that's being disputed here is the twitch
partner contract that is something that
every streamer has signed now it's
possible that may have changed in 2015
but I have to imagine there's a lot of
big streamers who are still streaming
today whose contracts are from 2015 the
same ones that phantom or signs judge
Carnell writes in his decision that the
$50,000 is overly harsh and unreasonably
and unfairly one-sided there is no
reason to limit a bargain to $50,000
when he might well be entitled to a much
much higher sum from a practical point
of view which i think is an essential
consideration limiting recovery to
$50,000
virtually kills off the odds of a suit
against which at all the agreement
doesn't appear to have an attorney fees
clause and few if any lawyers would take
on a contingency case against twitch for
some reasonable percentage of $50,000
but the judge is saying here is that not
only is the $50,000 just too low based
on what phantom Ward could have been
making on twitch in the time since he
was banned it's also too low for any
lawyer to be interested in taking the
case the judge noted that phantom Ward's
average income was around $5,000 a month
with high points at around 10
thousand dollars a month which makes
that $50,000 number pretty ridiculous in
this case again even when you consider
the fact that it wouldn't give a lawyer
any payday at all phantom Ward's lawyers
make some other claims about how the
contract might be unconscious they say
that while phantom Ward was just 26 and
living with his parents when he signed
the partner agreement twitch had a
lawyer write the contract for them which
sort of unbalances the whole situation
from the jump also hilariously phantom
Ward's legal team alleges that the
contract was also unconscionable because
parts of the contract were too hard to
read they say that the text was too
small and certain important clauses were
too far in the middle of the contract
and not right up top this is of course a
pretty weird claim and the judge goes in
on it saying that I mean obviously some
part of the contract is gonna have to be
in the middle not right up top he also
makes a point about how phantom Ward
clearly knows how to scroll through a
contract which that's hilarious all
right so we're through Vargas legal
offense which parts of it seem shaky but
that $50,000 thing is pretty solid and
really the judge's decision here
highlights something very important
which is partner agreements or at least
twitches Terms of Service in general
seems a little bit behind the times we
see it with all these switch banning
stories and now we're seeing it here
that $50,000 number is way too low and
let's assume for a second it's still in
play imagine if like Timbit hatman got
banned tomorrow is he only allowed to
sue twitch for $50,000 maybe ridiculous
he makes way more than that in like a
month again it's unclear if twitches
partner agreements have changed since
then but it's just one part of a huge
puzzle of twitch sort of not keeping up
with how big their own platform has gone
this case is still ongoing and it's
unclear if phantom Lord will get the
damages that he believes he's owed but
what it has done is shine a light on how
broken Twitch's partner contracts are or
at least were at one point if this
lawsuit goes phantom Wars way and there
are still many people under the same
contract well which could be on the hook
for a lot more than they ever thought
they would be
[Music]
that's just fine yeah Abin oh yeah but
and when I get out of here tell him to
ruin the Sean [ __ ] government isn't
what Devon does Devon just walks in the
back here and he thinks he owns the
place just cause he owns a home that's
all it is
Devon just thinks he can do whatever he
wants got news for you don't know me
[ __ ] [ __ ] Devon matter you know he's
leaving early kid he's got a like hire a
new servant the last one was too poor
for him that's telling you actually just
a tattoo of the of its first million
dollars that's what it is